[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie et aussi politique cette
semaine nous recevons Louis Boyard
bonjour bonjour et avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montana bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte bonjour Louis Boyard bonjour
vous êtes député la France insoumise du
Val-de-Marne depuis 2022 à seulement 22
ans vous faites partie des deux plus
jeunes députés de l'histoire on vous
connaît pour avoir refusé de serrer la
main aux députés RN alors de la première
séance à l'Assemblée nationale on vous
connaît aussi pour votre récent clash
avec Cyril Hanouna sur le plateau de
TPMP vous livrez un réquisitoire contre
Vincent Bolloré le propriétaire de la
chaîne C8 ce qui vous vaut des insultes
de l'animateur chouchou du milliardaire
vous avez mutuellement porté plainte
l'affaire n'a pas encore été jugée de
buzz donc à votre actif depuis votre
élection mais aucun au service des
Français à moins à moins que vous
n'osiez réservé la primeur des annonces
puisque votre menu est très politique
n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre exactement un
menu très économique est devenu beau
plan avec des spaghettis des dé au
poulet une sauce curry et on desserre on
se lâche un peu un Paris-Brest dans le
dessous des plats les CROUS au pylori
les étudiants ne mangent pas toujours à
leur faim et dans les pieds dans le plat
focus sur une application qui rend accro
à l'anti-gaspi allez on passe à table
tout de suite cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
alors Louis Boyard en découvrant votre
envie du jour je me suis dit il est trop
fort Boyard on a dû vous la faire mille
fois non et ce n'est pas possible vous
croyez vraiment à TPMP touche pas à mon
plat ou le boss serait la recette du
succès et oui car le buzz il est bien
tapis derrière ces banales pâtes au dés
de poulet sauce curry choix attention
Brigitte loin d'être innocent vous
l'avez déniché sur le compte Instagram
créé en 2020 d'imam 20 ans destiné aux
étudiants fauchés comment cuisiner
simple et pas cher moins de 60 euros par
mois jusque là rien à dire c'est même
carrément d'actualité mais il m'a imposé
sur les vidéos vêtue d'un voile
ostentatoire ce qui lui avait valu une
vague de cyber-harcèlement qu'il avait
même obligé à quitter les réseaux
sociaux sachant que les mots recettes
pâtes Curie et poulet génère 6 millions
140 000 résultats sur Google vous avez
trouvé le moyen Louis Boyard d'exhumer
cette recette en particulier à vous de
nous démontrer fourchette en main que
c'est bien le meilleur rapport qualité
prix sinon c'est bien du buzz sur le dos
du voile que si vous voulez nous faire
avaler à Brigitte et à moi comme un vrai
comme dans le vrai TPMP c'est pas vrai
mais il y a un mot qu'on ressort souvent
c'est le mot buzz et il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui disent il vient faire le
buzz mais mon buzz n'a pas vraiment de
sens la question c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait du bruit et c'est vrai que
parfois souvent malgré moi pour être
honnête vous voyez que ce soit pour
l'exemple de TPMP ou même de la main au
rassemblement national je m'attendais
pas à ce que ça parte autant en vrille
mais en fait c'est critiquer Vincent
Bolloré sur sa chaîne
honnêtement je m'attendais pas à ce que
ça parte à ce point là pareil pour la
rassemblement national mais j'ai encore
un peu de candeur mais mais l'objectif
c'est que à partir du moment où vous
avez des scènes comme ça qui font parler
l'objectif c'est de faire de la
politique sur ces scènes là à partir du
moment où elle se pose la question de
est-ce que oui ou non il faut serrer la
main au rassemblement national ou pas je
pose la question de savoir est-ce que
oui ou non on doit accepter
l'institutionnalisation du rassemblement
national et j'ai cité des noms de Simone
Veil et Jacques Chirac pour essayer un
peu de ramener la droite à ses valeurs
et assez convictions ils ont leur place
à la suite mais pourtant Jacques Chirac
et Simone Veil quand vous aurez répondu
que finalement il faut quand même lutter
contre l'institutionnalisation du
rassemblement national parce qu'on
compose avec le racisme ni avec
l'antisémitisme au moment où il y a eu
l'histoire avec Touche pas à mon poste
dire ne pas attendre les voix du
rassemblement national sur sa motion de
censure mais déjà le rassemblement
national il vote des lois avec Gérald
Darmanin j'entends pas les mêmes
discours de Power et d'autres après
ensuite sur la question de Touche pas à
mon poste c'est pareil l'objectif c'est
pas de faire parler de soi c'est de
faire parler de la concentration des
médias et donc du coup l'objectif c'est
justement de
pas fait exprès revenons à notre
assiette là c'est vraiment pour nous
parler donc
justement je veux vous parler de vous
parler de ces pâtes au curry à travers
tout ce que je vous dis avant c'est que
il y a des situations qu'on peut qui que
l'on peut créer qui permettent derrière
de poser un sujet politique et le sujet
politique que je veux poser ici c'est la
question de la précarité étudiante cette
recette à mon avis d'une vidéo qui est
retransmise par une fille voilée qui a
été victime dit-elle d'islamophobie donc
vous vouliez quand même avoir vous aviez
peut-être une petite arrière-pensée mais
restons sur le curry
mais ça même pas venu en tête mais bref
mais pour revenir
recette chez eslon 7
donc aujourd'hui j'ai la chance d'être à
côté d'avoir n'existe plus mais à
l'époque à l'époque je l'utilisais
beaucoup parce que quand j'étais
étudiant je vivais avec 300 400 euros
par mois avant de payer le loyer et donc
du coup bah je galérais quoi donc du
coup par exemple vous nourrir à l'époque
vous avez avec peut-être 45 euros par
mois pour pouvoir réussir à continuer de
manger et donc du coup bah souvent
c'était les pâtes et la bolognaise ça a
été beaucoup plus
c'était l'histoire des petits plaisirs
où j'allais sur rejette recette échelon
7 et du coup je voyais si vous rajouter
un peu de sauce un peu cuir et vous
rajoutez un peu de goût et donc du coup
c'est des petits plaisirs pas cher que
j'ai vécu et que beaucoup d'autres
vivent encore aujourd'hui et ça permet
d'en parler ça peut être une recette
très économique si on va chercher un
mauvais poulet dans un supermarché
consigné dans un bout de plastique et
puis des pâtes très bon marché et puis
du curé là encore le curé c'est pas très
cher mais si on va acheter un beau
poulet au boucher on découpe des petits
dés elle peut être trois fois plus cher
alors comment vous faisiez vous mais en
fait j'ai acheté de la malbouffe et vous
la masquez avec une sauce bah en fait au
moment où vous arrivez au supermarché
vous avez envie de bien manger puis
ensuite vous regardez votre compte en
banque et vous vous rendez compte que
vous n'avez pas le choix de prendre le
poulet le moins cher vous prenez donc du
coup vous prenez les premiers prix
prendre le premier prix et donc du coup
et ensuite pour les petits plaisirs
ensuite avec la sauce vous rajoutez vous
rajoutez un peu un peu d'épices voilà
piment curry et puis vous rajoutez un
petit peu de goût et donc du coup c'est
mon petit truc à moi du coup c'est de
rejoindre je rajoute des épices partout
parce que c'est comme ça que j'arrive à
donner du goût mais surtout avant
j'avais enfin j'avais pas appris à
cuisiner du coup j'ai commencé à
apprendre à cuisiner pendant le
confinement et qu'est-ce que beaucoup de
Français comme beaucoup de Français de
cuisiner que d'acheter des plats tout
fait quand on est étudiant oui bien sûr
ou parfois vous avez des petits plans
vous avez qui mangent seulement des
baguettes moi ça m'est arrivé à des
moments je faisais des choses aussi je
vous prenais pas de mie ketchup
mayonnaise et vous mangez ça mais voilà
c'était aussi des recettes on est aux
confins de la malbouffe
mais vous mais vous n'avez pas le choix
parce que c'est une question de choix
alors goûter parce que je suis sûr ce
que vous en pensez elles sont meilleurs
que les vôtres à mon avis
le curry est mieux dosé que chez moi
alors c'est le restaurant chez Françoise
qui nous a cuisiné évidemment c'est bon
petit plats trois choses à savoir sur le
curry en attendant Jean-Pierre je crois
que vous êtes en train de déguster votre
plat alors là je vous ai un peu pris de
cours mais oui
le mot curry vient de carie et on indien
désigne un plat en sauce avec de la
viande du poisson ou des légumes
parfumés par un mélange d'épices et le
vrai mélange d'épices en Inde ça
s'appelle le garam masala et non pas le
carré donc le charisme en fait ce curry
souvent appelé curry de Madras qui
contient notamment du curcuma d'où cette
couleur jaune du cumin du piment du
fenugrec des graines de moutarde de la
cardamome mais aussi de la cannelle il
aurait été inventé par les Anglais qui
l'ont ramené au pays après la
décolonisation de l'Inde pour pimenter
leur fat de cuisine on connaît la
cuisine anglaise c'est pas toujours très
relevé enfin ce curry c'est ensuite
invité dans la cuisine mondiale
internationale Chine Japon et en France
bien sûr tout le monde a un petit pot de
curry à la maison dans un placard et il
peut doper vous l'avez dit vous avez
raison une bé une sauce des pâtes du riz
il peut tout doper le curry et c'est
bien pratique pour masquer une mauvaise
viande ou une mauvaise patte
avec vous qu'on vous dites que la
cuisine anglaise parce que ma mère est
anglaise et alors mais non mais c'est
vrai que c'est une idée reçue c'est une
cuisine particulière il faut le
reconnaître mais alors il y a quelque
chose il y a dans la dans la nourriture
anglaise il y a quelque chose que
j'adore qui s'appelle la marmite je sais
pas si vous en avez déjà entendu parler
c'est une sorte de confiture de levure
de bière il me semble apprendre
au petit déjeuner et alors oui
exactement avec du beurre et alors c'est
excellent parce que c'est où vous aimez
ou vous n'aimez pas et bon 90% des gens
que je croise j'essaie n'aime pas à
chaque fois que j'essaie de leur faire
goûter donc du coup je suis un peu le
seul à aimer ça donc voilà je vous
invite les personnes qui nous écoutent à
essayer la marmite pour savoir si jamais
ils font partie de ces 10 % qui
apprécient cette confiture anglaise vous
aimez les plats qui sont un peu épicés
un peu qui sortent un peu de l'ordinaire
oui bah je découvre la nourriture en ce
moment pour être très franc parce que
bah à l'époque moi je vois je les
moments où j'ai commencé à cuisiner
c'était les moments où j'étais étudiant
et donc du coup en vrai c'était du riz
des pâtes un peu de sauce et des épices
et donc du coup élevé par des parents
qui faisait de la cuisine des
grands-mères ma mère était anglaise vous
comprenez que le rapport que vous avez
et donc et donc oui les épices moi j'en
mets j'en mets partout et encore
aujourd'hui j'en mets partout tout le
temps parce que bah ça change quoi vous
pouvez prendre un plat ça fait voyager
ça fait voyager vous pouvez prendre
n'importe quel plat vous changez vous
changez des épices et puis ça devient un
plan dans les carbonara vous mettiez des
épices alors les Italiens ils vont
hurler parce que là je viens de couper
mes pattes donc s'il y a des Italiens
qui me regardent je suis désolé et après
oui dans les carbonara je mettais des
épices moi j'adore le piment voilà je
m'étais je m'étais souvent du piment ça
change la couleur attention les épices
et le piment c'est deux choses
différentes les épices c'est ce qu'on
vient de dire c'est de la cannelle c'est
du poivre etc et les piments c'est les
piments et moi je vous en parle en
parlant de de ce petit de ce ouais une
petite étagère dans laquelle je mets moi
tout ce que j'appelle les épices vous
avez raison sans deux choses différentes
mais en gros tout ce qui peut permettre
d'assaisonner et relever le goût de bien
sûr alors qu'est-ce que vous savez faire
aujourd'hui si on vient dîner chez vous
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous proposer
ce que je qu'est-ce que je pourrais bien
vous cuisiner le bœuf non pas le bœuf
Bourguignon je très souvent
dans un un peu de vin oui mais enfin ma
grand-mère en fait des très bons et donc
du coup je compare
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas encore c'est
toujours mieux quand c'est mamie qui le
fait et donc non en vrai probablement
que je vous cuisinerai des pizzas parce
que j'ai alors ça c'est un autre sujet
mais non mais alors attendez non je
redoute le pire non parce que encore
des mauvaises tomates et c'est là où je
vous redonne parce que mon objectif dans
cette émission c'est d'essayer de donner
le plus d'astuces possible à des gens
qui ont pas beaucoup alors Imane pizza
aussi sur son compte j'ai vu mais elle
doit faire la pâte elle-même parce que
moi ce que je faisais c'est que je
prenais des pizzas vraiment pas cher
d'une pizza mais avec si peu de
garnitures que ça en devient honteux et
ensuite vous rajoutez la garniture et
bien sûr et comme ça ensuite je me
faisais des pizzas mais incroyable moi
j'avais l'impression d'être chez
Françoise qui a un bon restaurant à côté
de l'Assemblée nationale donc du coup je
pourrais essayer de vous cuisiner ça et
de vous convaincre que des recettes de
pizza Leader Price
ça peut être bon est-ce que vous dînez
au restaurant vous allez manger au
restaurant et ou alors c'est plutôt vous
êtes plutôt en mode street food parce
qu'on peut bien manger maintenant avec
instruction
aujourd'hui on a on a un emploi du temps
qui est tellement serré que donc du coup
on se retrouve à aller beaucoup à la
buvette d'aller au restaurant de
l'Assemblée nationale et il y a autre
chose que j'adore c'est le kebab le
kebab quand j'étais quand j'étais au
lycée c'était l'endroit où on se
retrouvait entre amis quand on voulait
pas aller manger au self et donc du coup
encore aujourd'hui je fais des
rendez-vous au kebab où j'emmène des
gens manger d'autres députés ou des
rendez-vous bien sûr
un petit peu plus haut de gamme aussi
mais alors déjà vous avez des très bons
kebabs et des excellentes le donneur
kebab que vous voulez vous la viande qui
est comme ça la viande là vous avez la
broche et alors vous avez je sais plus
je crois c'est le Parisien qui avait
fait une vidéo sur Youtube qui vous
permettait de repérer qu'elles étaient
les broches de bonne qualité ou de
mauvaise qualité vous regardez en
fonction voilà de la couleur de la
viande de la graisse qui ressort et donc
oui bon après par exemple si jamais
j'avais à rencontrer je sais pas
quelqu'un d'un autre groupe
parlementaire en vérité si peut-être que
je les emmènerai au kebab finalement
c'est toujours bon déjà premièrement et
puis enfin j'essaie de rester le plus
possible moi-même parce que vous avez
changé de statut maintenant vous êtes
député quand vous voulez vous taper la
cloche il va où lui Boyard mais je vais
au kebab j'ai un bon kebab non mais à
côté de chez moi j'ai un très bon kebab
ou les légumes sont frais ou les coupes
tout ça devant vous et bah oui parce que
déjà dans la ville où je vais moi j'ai
pas de restaurant enfin moi j'habite à
Villeneuve-Saint-Georges et à
Villeneuve-Saint-Georges là où je suis à
côté au centre-ville j'ai pas de
restaurant haut de gamme donc du coup je
vais au kebab du coin et puis aussi
parce que bah je reste je veux rester
qui je suis mais avec et avec mes amis
qu'est-ce que vous regardez sur la carte
c'est occasionnel du coup ça pas très
souvent si je comprends bien qu'est-ce
qui vous fait envie sur une carte c'est
plutôt de la viande plutôt du poisson je
suis très viande et je culpabilise parce
que
on va pas pouvoir continuer de manger de
la viande éternellement c'est pas de
programme politique dont je vous parle
c'est de réalité écologique donc
attention parce que si vos chefs vous
regardent vous tapez sur les doigts mes
chèvres
on a tous un rapport différent à la
chose mais par contre de fait il va
falloir avoir beaucoup de transformation
dans notre manière de vivre notamment de
manger et en fait la une telle
consommation de viande n'est pas
compatible avec une harmonie entre être
humain et nature changé vos pratiques
deux fois par semaine j'essaie de
j'essaie d'être raisonnable oui j'ai
réduit la consommation parce que depuis
qu'on est ici moi avant je faisais du
sport j'étais bien j'ai pris 5 kg là
j'ai monsieur reposé j'ai repédu trois
kilos donc et ensuite là après on va
manger un Paris-Brest et donc vous avez
des déserts à foison devant vous donc du
coup vous vous mettez en manger plein et
donc du coup il faut essayer de se
contrôler un petit peu et puis manger de
la viande tous les jours c'est mauvais
donc j'essaie de j'essaie de me
contrôler un petit peu deux fois par
semaine mais de la bonne viande de la de
qualité du label rouge
de la bonne viande quoi de je regarde
celle qui me semble qu'il sait qui me
fait le plus en vie mais parce que
aujourd'hui j'en ai la chance
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on doit être à
28% d'augmentation de de ce type de
produit donc là vous voyez je sais pas
si c'est du poulet premier prix ou pas
mais aujourd'hui nous on peut se
permettre dans discuter alors que pour
certaines personnes ce n'est même pas
imaginable que d'acheter une telle
viande et quand je vous disais que bah
moi je vais encore au kebab avec mes
amis parce que bah c'est ma vie j'essaie
de rester le plus possible connecté à la
vie des gens des millions de personnes
qu'on est censés représenter vous vous
faites vos courses dans les supermarchés
où vous allez dans les petits commerces
de proximité sur le marché le dimanche
être au contact des producteurs comment
vous faites aujourd'hui quand je suis
sur un marché c'est avec un tract c'est
donc difficile de pouvoir porter tout ce
qui est avec mais oui de temps en temps
j'essaie de faire des petites achats et
puis sinon j'ai un supermarché à côté de
chez moi où je vais et où vous faites le
gros de vos courses
on a peu le temps de bien manger quand
c'est pas au restaurant on a peu le
temps de cuisiner donc du coup souvent
je m'achète des repas tout fait quoi je
retourne à la bonne vieille pasta box ou
à la pizza réchauffée sachez que c'est
le pire ça c'est pas tout préparé ils
sont très salés ils vont encore mieux
les nutriscors par exemple sur les tout
préparés parce que c'est souvent
compliqué
justement il y a une époque j'ai essayé
de le faire parce que avant je m'étais
mis au sport et je m'étais donné une
détermination dans l'alimentation et je
ne mangeais si ce n'était pas à minima B
je ne mange pas et aujourd'hui c'était
enfin on a plus le temps de faire du
sport et donc du coup bah quand j'arrive
au supermarché et que je vois la Poste à
box je ne regarde plus les lettres les
deux là pasta box c'est un support mais
mais c'est aussi un autre problème c'est
que la nourriture transformée c'est la
nourriture la moins chère et c'est celle
qui derrière vous donne le plus de
problèmes de santé notamment des
problèmes d'obésité c'est pour ça que
quand vous enfin souvent en fait quand
vous êtes précaire vous avez des
problèmes d'obésité justement à cause de
cette nourriture transformée et pour
nous dans notre programme partager de la
nups c'est important de de parler bio on
a besoin de 300 000 agriculteur de plus
pour pouvoir faire de la nourriture bio
pour toutes et tous
les gens l'achètent moins et c'est pour
ça que aujourd'hui nous on a un échec du
bureau les écolos ont beaucoup misé sur
le bureau et du pince aussi mais
aujourd'hui rien que ce marché il y a
pas de véritable politique
je pense que je pense qu'il faut un
ministère de l'alimentation qui soit
extrêmement volontariste sur
l'organisation de la production du bio
je pense aussi que il faut de fait vous
avez raison c'est beaucoup trop cher
pour beaucoup de gens donc du coup il va
falloir peut-être se poser la question
pourquoi est-ce que certaines personnes
ne peuvent pas acheter du bio je vous
donne un exemple les étudiants parce que
je vous dis à une question que j'aime
bien poser c'est combien d'étudiants
vivent avec moins de 1100 euros par mois
soit le seuil de pauvreté la
quasi-totalité même quand vous êtes un
enfant de classe aisé donc pourquoi
est-ce que ces étudiants peuvent pas
manger du bio parce qu'ils sont pauvres
donc du coup il faut peut-être se poser
la question pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont
pauvres et donc donner des mesures qui
leur permettent de gagner de pouvoir
d'achat une seule chose avant de passer
au coup c'est un peu plus compliqué que
ça le Sri Lanka va essayer à l'échelle
du pays de devenir le premier pays 100%
bio du monde et bien et les
consommateurs n'ont acheter parce que
c'était trop cher et les agriculteurs
n'ont pas été rémunérés au juste prix et
tout ça s'est écroulé aujourd'hui c'est
un vrai fiasco donc on peut en tirer
aussi les conséquences en parlant de
subventions c'est pour ça veut dire
qu'il faudrait dépenser beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent pour maintenir ce
marché bien sûr déjà c'est intéressant
de regarder les erreurs qu'on peut faire
les autres pour ne pas les reproduire et
ensuite sur la fin j'insiste sur le fait
qu'il va falloir planifier les choses il
va falloir organiser un certain moment
par exemple on est pour le blocage pour
le blocage de prix des prix voilà pour
nous les fruits les légumes il faut
avoir des prix bloqués pour permettre à
tout le monde de pouvoir manger des
fruits et légumes ce qui n'est pas le
cas mais j'aime bien poser la question
autrement si on ne fait pas du bio on
fait quoi parce que le réchauffement
climatique il est là l'obligation de
changer nos modes de production et de
consommation elle est là donc du coup de
fait il va falloir le faire dans toutes
les personnes qui nous disent non
produire du bio c'est beaucoup trop
compliqué ce sera pas accessible pour
les gens nous ce qu'on explique c'est
que 300 000 agriculteurs de plus arrêté
avec l'agriculture intensive passé à la
permaculture et derrière aussi bah pour
que les personnes puissent acheter du
bio et ben il faut augmenter leur
pouvoir d'achat donc par exemple
augmenter les salaires pour nourrir
toutes les possibilités
de nourrir tout le monde c'est bien un
pays qui a pas à se poser des questions
sur ce sujet c'est la France on a on a
des dés très fortement et c'est pour ça
qu'il va falloir que c'est pour ça qu'il
va falloir très fortement les aider et
notamment il y a des agriculteurs qui
essayent vous savez je suis dans une
circonce dans ma circonscription il y a
le plateau briard et là-bas vous avez
des agriculteurs qui essaient de faire
de la permaculture qui essaient de faire
du bio et ce qu'ils expliquent c'est que
ils se retrouvent face à des industries
qui sont mais si grandes si puissantes
que ils sont écrasés sur le marché et
donc du coup il s'en sortent pas et là
encore une fois c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il faut un ministère de
l'alimentation et de l'agriculture et
que derrière on planifie et donc que si
jamais il y a des grands industriels qui
veulent manger des parts du marché bah
l'état il a drôle venir et de dire bah
en fait non finalement ça va pas se
passer comme ça c'est ce que nous on
appelle la planification et ce sera au
service à la fois des agriculteurs
si vous êtes vraiment incollable le
voyage c'est le quiz
alors votre meilleur ennemi aujourd'hui
Cyril Hanouna est affublé d'un surnom
Baba tout droit sorti d'une pâtisserie
seriez-vous nous dire Louis Boyen qui a
inventé le baba au rhum déjà alors
Marie-Antoine Carême qui était la star
des pâtissiers sous Napoléon
BPI le pâtissier de Catherine Médicis ce
n'est pas rien Nicolas Stoer le
pâtissier de Stanislas premier le roi de
Pologne enfin des Gaston Lenôtre qui a
inventé cette délicieuse pâtisserie le
baba au rhum déjà
mon problème s'est passé
c'est bien c'est Nicolas vous le saviez
ou vous l'avez dit au pif j'ai eu une
intuition
pour la petite histoire Brigitte Stoer
pour réveiller un kouglof trop sec il a
rajouté du vin liquoreux ce qui lui a
redonné un peu de moelleux et ensuite
donc le baba était né c'est après qu'on
a rajouté du rhum au lieu de se vaincre
bravo bah merci beaucoup alors deuxième
quiz attention on va voir si vous allez
faire aussi bien question précocité vous
êtes une référence puisque à 22 ans vous
êtes l'un des deux plus jeunes députés
de l'Assemblée seriez-vous nous dire
qu'elle est le plus jeune chef à avoir
remporté une étoile ah Paul Bocuse B
Anne-Sophie Pic c'est Juliette chiant
des Joël Robuchon
et non c'est une femme Julia c'est
l'étudiant c'est en 2016 et elle avait
21 ans elle était excessivement jeune
voilà
dans cette émission on s'intéresse aussi
beaucoup à ses repas politiques et
souvent on sait que des petites
histoires se nous autour de ses repas et
que c'est là que se fait la petite et la
grande histoire c'est la brève de
comptoir
alors on vous a demandé le Boyard de
réfléchir à une anecdote autour d'un
repas et pourquoi pas en politique
est-ce qu'il y en a une qui vous est
revenue à l'esprit alors bon déjà outre
le fait que je fasse des repas avec des
députés dans des kebabs il y en a une
parce que je l'ai rejoins mon objectif
c'est de vous donner le plus d'astuces
possible je fais des rendez-vous enfin
j'ai fait maintenant je n'en fais plus
des rendez-vous à IKEA à IKEA vous avez
tout à fait syndicaux parce qu'avant
j'étais dans un des beaucoup dans le
syndicalisme et donc du coup là-bas vous
avez des hot-dogs notamment des hot-dogs
végétariens pas cher et donc du coup bah
voilà et Ikea
non voiture quand il y en avait qu'il y
avait des voitures on y allait et l'idée
pour ces 10 euros en essence pour aller
acheter j'ai pas le permis donc du coup
c'était la personne qui allait mais du
coup on me disait où est-ce que où
est-ce que où est-ce qu'on va aller et
donc du coup enfin je dis bon on va Ikea
et donc les gens ils s'interrogent mais
pourquoi est-ce que tu veux m'emmener à
IKEA je leur dis allez fais-moi
confiance et puis les gens découvrent et
donc c'est possible de faire des
rencontres amoureuses à IKEA parce que
aujourd'hui oui c'est vrai
mais non parce que derrière vous déjà
vous allez visiter des meubles que vous
pouvez pas vous acheter et ensuite
derrière vous allez prendre EPS
l'objectif c'est aussi de découvrir des
choses de partager des choses de
surprendre un petit peu donc du coup
Ikea très bonne astuce je recommande
c'est le hot dog végétarien aussi
personnellement vous qui êtes amateur de
viande donc c'est quand même ouais mais
certains moments les plats végétariens
sont bien meilleurs que les plats avec
de la viande et je pense que IKEA est le
meilleur exemple en la matière et
d'ailleurs je m'inquiète parce que enfin
je m'inquiète peut-être que ça serait
une bonne chose mais imaginez si jamais
il casse mettez à faire du fast food non
mais moi j'y réfléchi peut-être qu'il
regarde mais il y a quelque chose parce
que aujourd'hui aussi dans le rapport
qu'on peut avoir avec la nourriture les
McDo les burgers Kings avec du gras ou
trans c'est pas sain et donc quand je
dis qu'il va falloir avoir des
changements de nos modes de production
et de consommation aussi dans dans
l'imaginaire qu'on renvoie à la
nourriture peut-être qu'il va falloir
réfléchir à donner un imaginaire simple
de la nourriture et donc du coup
Ikea a un filon scandinave
effectivement Kessen avec du poisson et
ça m'a effectivement chaque fois que je
vais à IKEA le petit resto plein il y a
beaucoup de monde
[Rires]
on va vous donner de l'alimentation
vous allez le voir parfois nos étudiants
ne mangent pas à leur fin c'est ce que
vous nous disiez il y a quelques
instants le voyage c'est le dessous des
plats
et oui les étudiants se ruent dans les
dans les restaurants universitaires du
CROUS avec la hausse des prix de
l'alimentation il profite des tarifs
très préférentiels pratiqués grâce à
l'aide de l'État mais prix d'assaut
l'offre a du mal à suivre les quantités
et la qualité s'en ressentent d'après
une étude 56% des étudiants disent ne
pas manger à leurs faim reportage Hélène
Bonduelle voici les plats qui ont fait
polémiques à l'université de Rennes 2 en
début d'année des assiettes à moitié
vides et pas vraiment rassasiantes pour
les étudiants c'est le syndicat union
pirate qui dénonçait ses repas
insuffisants deux mois après nous sommes
allés sur le campus voir si le CROUS
avait revu ses offres là je pense que
c'est revenu un peu c'est mieux depuis
les vacances de la Toussaint je pense on
peut prendre trois articles alors
qu'avant on pouvait en prendre que deux
donc là on a pu faire rentrer plat
dessert donc c'est déjà mieux par
rapport à la rentrée quoi puis il y a
plus de choix
le CROUS de Bretagne qui n'a pas
souhaité nous répondre reconnaît avoir
baissé ses quantités
explique dans ce communiqué comme
certaines d'entre elles n'apparaissent
pas suffisamment rassasiantes elles
seront donc revues mais pour avoir le
choix des menus encore faut-il arriver
tôt sinon le risque c'est de faire une
heure de queue et d'arriver devant des
stands vides donc là le stand 2 est fini
donc c'est des pizzas et les pâtes il y
en a plus aujourd'hui il est 13h25 en
gros deux étudiants du syndicat pirate
acceptent de filmer leur passage au
selfos de la rentrée mais bon au niveau
des desserts par exemple
deux choix différents d'entrée il y
avait trois choix différents
la réalité c'est Karen comme dans la
plupart des universités avec l'inflation
le nombre d'étudiants qui vient manger
dans les restaurants universitaires a
augmenté de 20% et le Crous a parfois du
mal à suivre
la principale raison de tout ça c'est le
manque de budget dans les CROUS et où
justement pour pouvoir
réaliser l'ensemble de leurs missions
c'est à dire les résidences
universitaires la vie étudiante etc etc
elles sont un objet de renier sur
certaines dépenses pouvoir faire face en
fait à la crise qui sont en train de
passer pour beaucoup même le tarif
social de 3,30 € pour les boursiers est
encore trop élevé
[Musique]
quand même
ce soir là 230 jeunes attendent devant
l'épicerie gratuite tenue par des
étudiants de la fac tous une pension
mais qui est juste assez pour payer mon
loyer du coup je peux pas vraiment
manger en plus chez moi obligé de venir
ici trois jours par semaine pour pour
pouvoir manger une semaine mais c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu un petit peu
embêtant de louper deux heures dans ma
journée juste pour me nourrir quoi pour
réviser me faire des fiches préparer mes
partiels et à la place je suis là
attendre pendant deux heures quoi ici
les bénévoles récupèrent des invendus de
supermarché ou des surplus de cantine
scolaires ou d'hôpitaux pour les
redistribuer
avec autant d'épinards que vous voulez
là les petits légumes en fin de vie
pareil tout ce que vous voulez et après
soit une poignée de tomates soit une
poignée de raisin moi j'ai du pain de
mie du poisson de petits trucs comme ça
et j'ai deux yaourts une poignée de
tomate et moi j'ai du poivron des crêpes
du poulet aussi ça fait du bien quoi ça
coûte un peu cher en surface donc c'est
cool qu'on en est là quoi ouais et puis
ça permet aussi de varier et de quand
même enfin avoir une bonne conscience de
on a mangé équilibré quand même selon
l'association cop1 Solidarité étudiante
85% des étudiants assurent avoir déjà
sauté un repas faute d'argent
alors on le voit les étudiants se
roulent ruent dans les CROUS et vous
aviez posé récemment une photo d'un
sandwich c'était à Rennes sandwich ou
effectivement il y a pas grand chose à
l'intérieur de la baguette est-ce que
pour autant vous diriez que c'est
vraiment qu'on peut généraliser que tous
les CROUS sont comme ça que tous les
restos sont comme ça on a vu que là les
jeunes avaient retrouvé peut-être moins
de choix mais quand même des quantités
plus normales déjà sur la question de la
généralisation j'aimerais enfin que les
gens se rendent compte que c'est pas des
faits isolé c'est une immense partie et
presque majorité d'étudiants qui vivent
dans ces situations là on parle de
millions de personnes et pour les CROUS
c'est pareil il a ils disent on a réduit
on a fait moins de choix pour pouvoir
donner plus vous vous rendez compte que
enfin les choix qui sont obligés de
faire les CROUS aujourd'hui tellement
ils ont peu de moyens mais on va l'ont
même plus loin
c'est pas très grave de pas avoir le
sujet le sujet n'est pas dans le CROUS
c'est même c'est même un sujet qui va
au-delà ça veut dire que aujourd'hui
vous faites des études on est obligé de
mettre en place toutes sortes de
dispositifs pour vous loger pour vous
nourrir je veux dire on parlait de kebab
tout à l'heure même les kebabs font des
formules étudiantes tellement il est
institutionnalisé dans le pays que quand
vous faites des études vous les ferez en
étant pauvre je repose cette question
combien d'étudiants vivent sous le
soleil de pauvreté la quasi totalité et
aujourd'hui
les repas à 1 € sont ouverts
ils sont ouverts au boursiers seulement
vous avez 25% des étudiants ils sont
ouverts maintenant à plus de plus de
d'étudiants jusqu'à Noël et après ils
devront prouver leurs revenus donc du
coup en fait vous avez une grande partie
de des étudiants la majorité qui ne
profitent pas des repas 1 2 roues et
pourtant le gouvernement ne parle que de
ça mais aussi en fait vous avez des
CROUS qui sont pas ouvert le soir donc
du coup en fait vous avez des étudiants
qui se retrouvent ou sinon le coût pour
aller manger le soir il est beaucoup
trop loin c'est là il y a aussi ses
boutiques avec des des distributions de
biens et d'aliments gratuits et ensuite
du coup on se retrouve à un deuxième
point c'est que vous avez des étudiants
qui sont obligés de s'auto-organiser et
de prendre de important d'études pour
aller essayer de trouver des produits
gratuits à donner à d'autres étudiants
vous dites à l'état mettez plus de
moyens pour les CROUS ouvrez plus de
restos universitaires
malheureusement l'obstruction du
gouvernement empêchant d'en discuter une
proposition là pour une allocation
d'autonomie 2102 euros pour tous les
étudiants je donc là on se dirait donner
1100 € à tous les étudiants c'est
scandaleux pourquoi c'est pas c'est pas
justifiable mais le grand âge par
exemple les grands cette proposition là
elle a pas été votée en commission elle
a pas été votée en commission et
d'ailleurs elle a été rejeté de façon
absolument scandaleuse comment vous
l'expliquez que vous n'arriviez pas à
convaincre alors qu'il y a une réalité
et que vous proposez parce que la classe
parce que ils se rendent pas compte les
députés se rendent pas compte de ce
matin mais ça sert à rien d'essayer de
les convaincre ils sont trop déconnectés
et à chaque fois que vous leur dites que
il y a de la pression
juste pour terminer sur les députés ils
arrêtent pas de dire oui nous aussi on a
travaillé pendant nos études oui mais
eux ils ont réussi ils ont terminé à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a l'immense
partie des étudiants ils ont pas réussi
et aujourd'hui ils continuent de vivre
dans la misère et ces gens-là la député
il porte jamais leur voix et ensuite que
ce que je propose c'est une allocation
d'autonomie de 1100 euros pour tous les
étudiants je vous explique pourquoi tout
ça en fonction du revenu pour une raison
très simple à l'époque on finançait le
grand âge la vie des grands-parents via
une solidarité familiale sauf que dans
un pays où vous avez 10 millions de
pauvres vous ne pouvez pas demander aux
familles de supporter la vie du grand
âge donc du coup on est passé d'une
solidarité familiale à une solidarité
nationale et donc on a organisé via les
caisses de sécurité sociale est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas partir du principe que la
jeunesse et comme le grand âge un âge de
la vie qui qui ne peut pas être
uniquement protégé via la solidarité
familiale est-ce qu'on peut pas
réfléchir la jeunesse comme un âge de la
vie où on doit passer à de la solidarité
nationale déjà parce que en fait ce
n'est pas possible de faire des études
uniquement financées par votre famille
parce que bah en fait la plupart des
familles de ce pays ne peuvent pas
financer des études ou bien une famille
qui peuvent les financer donc pourquoi
laisser un pays ou quasiment tout est
gratuit on peut aller à l'école
gratuitement à l'université pour très
peu d'argent on peut pas on peut pas par
exemple aller à l'école gratuitement il
y a le fournisseurs scolaires on nous on
distribue des fournitures scolaires
parce que il y a des aides quand même
accessible déjà obligatoires et plus
elle est
je vous assure que on vous parlant moi
de l'endroit où des endroits où je suis
élu que l'école n'est pas accessible
pour tout le monde et qu'en fait vous
avez des enfants qui vont à l'école et
qui n'ont pas de stylo et qui sont
constamment obligés d'aller les
emprunter à d'autres élèves que de dire
que l'État a mis en place des choses on
peut le dire je vais pas dire l'état de
fait rien de dire à l'État a mis en
place des choses qui permettent à tout
le monde d'avoir accès à égalité à
l'éducation j'affirme que ce n'est pas
le cas que ce n'est pas le cas que ce
soit pour dans le primaire le collège ou
le lycée où vous avez un problème sur la
distribution des fournitures scolaires
et c'est particulièrement pas le cas
dans l'accès aux études supérieures
parce que vous avez des étudiants qui se
disent enfin des lycéens qui se disent
moi je vais tout simplement pas aller à
la fac parce que je sais que mes parents
ils ont pas les moyens de payer le
logement je sais que j'arriverai pas à
suivre elle a quand même relevé les APL
elle a relevé les bourses elle a limité
les loyers du CROUS il y a eu quand même
des choses qui ont été faites pour les
étudiants
sont absolument scandaleuses vraiment la
ministre elle a été scandaleux sur ce
coup-là parce que déjà pendant le covid
on avait pu voir qu'il y avait une
précarité étudiante qui était explosive
elle dit on a augmenté les bourses de 4
%. merci Madame on est à 6 % d'inflation
et pour les produits qui achètent les
étudiants c'est à dire des produits
alimentaires particulièrement on a bien
plus que 6 % autrement dit elle n'a pas
augmenté les bourses suffisamment haut
pour compenser l'inflation et je le
rappelle seulement 25% des étudiants
touchent les bourses ce qui veut dire
que vous avez 75% des étudiants qui
n'ont pas été concernés par sa mesure
elle a dit on a augmenté les aides au
logement de 3,5% parce que les loyers
ont augmenté de 3,5%. mais le montant
des loyers est bien supérieur au montant
des aides au logement autrement dit les
étudiants ont perdu de l'argent donc
vous avez une classe d'âge qui est dans
une misère obligée d'aller à la
distribution alimentaire ou de revenons
justement ce qui permet pas de les
sortir de la misère dans laquelle ils
sont voilà pourquoi revenons au CROUS
puisque on a vu tout à l'heure une
étudiante qui dit il y a beaucoup il y a
25% d'augmentation au CROUS tout le
monde va au CROUS il y a peut-être même
des abus des gens qui vont au CROUS
alors qu'ils n'ont rien à mais alors
qu'est-ce que vous préconisez vous ce
qu'il faut renflouer les caisses du
CROUS comment il faut faire pour pour
éviter
ces plats Reiki et ses étudiants
plusieurs choses
j'insiste sur le fait de que je demande
à la particularité au gouvernement et la
représentation nationale de considérer
la jeunesse comme un âge de la vie qui
ne peut pas uniquement survivre grâce à
une solidarité familiale et qui doit
donc qui a donc besoin d'une solidarité
nationale ensuite donc pour moi la
solution à l'occasion d'autonomie
premièrement ensuite deuxièmement sur
les CROUS vous avez la question des
logements où il y a un immense problème
de logement CROUS il y a besoin d'en
construire 200000 par an et il y a aussi
la question de la rénovation des CROUS
parce que aujourd'hui vous allez dans
certaines universités ou certains CROUS
il fait froid mais un froid impossible
quoi justement parce que c'est mal isolé
donc ça c'est un plan Marshall pour les
CROUS investir pour les restaurants pour
les au-delà au-delà d'un plan Marshall
pour l'écrousse un plan Marshall pour
l'éducation parce que vous avez en fait
on ne pourra pas faire la planification
écologique sans avoir des une jeunesse
extrêmement modifier extrêmement
qualifié dans le supérieur mais
extrêmement qualifié aussi dans la voie
professionnelle la voie professionnelle
c'est l'indispensable de la
planification écologique donc là aussi
nous cette proposition de loi on veut
élargir au lycéen de la voie
professionnelle il faut comprendre que
si jamais vous n'avez pas une jeunesse
qui est qualifié une jeunesse qui est
formée alors derrière vous manquez de
main d'oeuvre qualifiée avec 1000
difficultés particulièrement au moment
où vous voulez faire la planification
écologique beaucoup beaucoup d'étudiants
ont travaillé pendant leurs études
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
allocation d'autonomie vous proposez
elle doit y avoir des contreparties en
face est-ce que par exemple les
étudiants doivent donner quelques heures
de leur temps pour aider la collectivité
les contreparties les étudiants les
donneront quand ils ont 20-30 ans plus
tard quand eux-mêmes derrière auront un
travail et payeront des cotisations des
impôts ça s'appelle la solidarité
nationale pour la question du travail
étudiant c'est la première cause d'échec
en licence parce que les députés de la
République en marche et du RN ils
arrêtent pas dire oui nous aussi on a
travaillé pendant les études c'est pas
vrai les deux tiers ils l'ont pas fait
et en plus ceux qui sont parce qu'ils
ont réussi combien ont raté après
ensuite il y a une frustration quand
vous avez des étudiants qui ont
travaillé la moitié de l'année et qui se
retrouvent assis à côté d'un autre
étudiant qui lui n'a pas eu à travailler
parce qu'il vient d'une famille aisée où
est l'égalité républicaine il y a le
l'idée du chèque alimentation aussi qui
revient un peu dans l'atmosphère ça a
pas pu se faire le ministre des Finances
à Eddy que c'était un peu compliqué à
mettre en place mais qui continuait à y
réfléchir vous vous y êtes favorable
vous pensez qu'on pourrait le faire ou
vous préférez le blocage des prix je
préfère le blocage des prix premièrement
parce qu'on dit les prix augmentent non
c'est pas les prix augmentent c'est des
gens font augmenter les prix et il faut
regarder qui et pourquoi et il y en a
qui abusent donc déjà premièrement il y
a des prix qui va falloir bloquer
particulièrement sur ceux qui abusent
ensuite je ne pense pas qu'il faille
résoudre la situation vous visez là je
pense au chocolat par exemple
la grande distribution aussi monsieur
Leclerc qui en avait parlé qui avait
expliqué qu'il y avait des abus et
ensuite derrière d'où viennent les
abusky
vous avez vous avez des personnes qui
aujourd'hui font de la spéculation par
exemple sur le prix de l'essence sur le
prix de l'essence ce n'est pas
raisonnable et surtout bloquer les prix
de l'essence d'autant que en plus ils
font des supers profits comme jamais ils
partagent à peine aux salariés et
derrière aujourd'hui on se retrouve à
avoir trop peu de moyens dans les
caisses de l'État et donc du coup des
écoles qui sont même plus capables de
chauffer les enfants dans des écoles
primaires sur le chocolat il y a
peut-être une petite spéculation j'en
sais rien mais il y a une raréfaction de
de l'offre il y a une augmentation de la
demande le réchauffement fait que des
pays ne peuvent plus produire de cacao
donc il y a aussi des dérèglements
climatiques des dérèglements et entre
l'offre et la demande qui font que les
prix montent d'accord et uniquement et
donc et donc du coup ensuite pendant que
il y a nous enfin en fait les gens quoi
normaux ceux qui sont pas des
milliardaires qui se retrouvent à avoir
à assumer 20 euros d'augmentation en
plus qui est énorme quand vous vivez
avec juste un SMIC vous allez me faire
croire qu'il y a pas des gens qui sont
en train de se mettre plein les poches
dans la période je veux dire le pays n'a
jamais été aussi riche c'est juste que
les richesses n'ont jamais été aussi mal
partagées Bernard Arnault sa fortune à
la quasiment doublé depuis les quatre
cinq dernières années je veux dire en
fait des richesses il y en a faut juste
voir où est-ce qu'elles sont accumulées
et surtout faut voir moi je suis pour
une répartition des richesses mais il
faut réfléchir pourquoi est-ce qu'on
veut répartir les richesses parce que
selon moi il y a des biens qui devraient
être des biens communs par exemple l'eau
est un bien commun l'eau n'a pas
fluctuer sur un marché la nourriture est
un bien commun la nourriture n'a pas à
fluctuer sur un marché pourquoi parce
que vous avez certains consommations qui
font partie de la dignité humaine et ne
pas pouvoir se loger et la demande et
qu'on a besoin de ça d'aliments on en
met n'importe quoi est-ce que le
logement j'interroge est-ce que le
logement l'eau et la nourriture devrait
fluctuer sur un marché où est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas se dire que on va bloquer
les prix voilà est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
dire que sur certains sujets et bien les
dividendes il y a pas alimentaire de
fait il va falloir faire un
souverainisme alimentaire parce que vous
ne pourrez pas européen et bien à
l'échelle européenne pourquoi pas mais
il va aussi falloir réfléchir à nous
avoir notre propre indépendance en
matière alimentaire parce que ce ne sera
plus possible d'avoir les enfin de de
d'importer autant de nourriture de enfin
d'apporter autant de viande par exemple
des États-Unis enfin de en fait ce sera
plus possible de transporter autant de
marchandises dans une société qui se
veut écologique et donc du coup il va
falloir réfléchir à produire les choses
nous-mêmes et c'est ça que je veux
plaider c'est ça que je veux plaider les
pays qui inscrit je crois le droit à
avoir de l'eau dans le dans la
Constitution par exemple il y a une
financarisation du marché de l'eau qui
peut prendre des proportions Terry pour
certains pays alors que les sécheresses
se multiplient et c'est bien normal
parce que ne pas pouvoir manger ne pas
pouvoir boire ne pas pouvoir se loger
c'est une atteinte à la dignité humaine
et notre notre société française elle a
quand même été basée basée sur des
droits humains qui font de la dignité
humaine et quand vous avez quelqu'un qui
dort dans la rue parce que le marché de
l'immobilier est vorace et bien je dis
que la dignité humaine de cette personne
est attaquée que la France a menti quand
elle a dit que elle était la nation des
droits de l'homme aujourd'hui sur
l'accès à l'eau sur l'accès à la
nourriture sur l'accès au logement sur
l'accès à tant de choses qui sont
fondatrices de la dignité humaine la
France ment on va continuer sur ce même
on va parler des désinvendus dans les
commerces parce que les applis pour
mettre en adéquation vendeur et
acheteurs se multiplient mais
s'adresse-t-elle au plus précaire et
bien on en parle et on met les pieds
dans le plat
et oui brigitte c'est l'appli anti-gaspi
qui cartonne tout good to go un je crois
qu'il est né au Danemark qui a recense
des invendus et coulis après réduit
grâce à un clic vous pouvez acheter en
début de soirée des croissants qui ne
l'ont pas trouvé preneur le matin ou des
légumes un peu abîmés après cassés c'est
un reportage de Maïté Frémont et de
Charlotte Sébire
comme tous les soirs depuis deux ans
avant de fermer son épicerie Julien a
une dernière corde à son arc mettre en
vente sur une application ces produits
abîmés pour éviter qu'ils partent à la
poubelle vous avez le nombre de paniers
disponibles donc aujourd'hui on en a un
et après vous mettez l'heure de collecte
donc c'est une tranche horaire par
exemple entre 18h et 19h
c'est tout simple
moi c'est les produits que je sais que
le lendemain je ne pourrai pas les
vendre mais ça ne va pas parce que je
peux pas les vendre qui ne sont pas
consommables c'est esthétiquement
parlant c'est pas très vendeur ça donne
pas vraiment envie que ça soit un petit
peu fripé ou légèrement marqué et donc
on préfère justement les mettre dans les
paniers tout au Togo plutôt que que les
vents de clients l'application utilisée
par Julien tout good to go en français
trop bon pour être jeté elle répertorie
35000 commerçants un peu partout en
France du boulanger au supermarché en
passant par les restaurants le panier de
fruits et légumes sera en ligne pendant
une heure une solution
anti-gaspillage qui fait gagner dans le
même temps du pouvoir d'achat Aude donc
là j'ai allumé mon application et en
fait je clique sur réserver une fois que
j'ai sélectionné mon panier
j'ai compris
réservé avec la carte ce soir là elle
est la première à repérer l'offre de
Julien bonjour
je viens récupérer un panier de tout Go
le panier il est juste là je vais vous
montrer ça alors aujourd'hui nous avons
des épinards des champignons sont
légèrement ouverts
100% surprise pour le consommateur 4 kg
de fruits et légumes d'une valeur de 21
euros largement soldée à 6,99 € sur ce
prix too good to go prendra une
commission de 1 euro
un petit revenu financier il y a rien à
dire c'est indéniable avec ce système au
d'économie chaque mois 150 euros sur sa
facture
donc c'était plus pour faire des
économies sur voilà des paniers et puis
maintenant c'est aussi un petit peu
lassitude de trouver des idées de repas
le soir je pense que tout le monde en
fait tout le monde fait attention même
les foyers les plus voilà les plus
modestes au plus élevés comme Aude un
Français sur 5 utilise l'application
l'inflation une aubaine pour cette
start-up française 6 ans après sa
création aujourd'hui 40% de
l'alimentation qu'on produit et
gaspiller de la fourche à la fourchette
quand on sait qu'il y a près d'un
milliard de personnes qui vivent en
situation précarité alimentaire c'était
pour nous une aberration depuis 2016 45
millions de paniers ont été sauvés too
good to go est aujourd'hui implanté dans
17 pays
alors vous qui voulez vous toujours vous
nourrir à petit prix vous avez pas cette
appli c'est un comble il faut
immédiatement vous la mettre dans votre
smartphone je connais je connaissais des
gens qui qui avaient cette application
enfin qu'ils l'ont toujours d'ailleurs
je trouve que cette application est
géniale et je pense que elle va même se
généraliser parce que en fait quand on
pense la politique il faut constamment
penser à comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
ne jamais gaspiller pour essayer de
trouver le au plus près de chez soi et
cette application c'est sur la
nourriture mais par exemple sur
l'électroménager vous en avez aussi j'ai
plus de nos applications mais je m'étais
fait tout mon électricité généralise à
tous les segments de la consommation et
il faut il faut c'est un indispensable
et c'est pas uniquement un indispensable
en France c'est un indispensable pour
tous les pays du monde mais vous vous
pensez que un étudiant il peut
s'intéresser à ce genre de panier parce
qu'il sait pas très bien ce qui va
trouver il sait pas s'il va avoir un
repas complet est-ce que vraiment ça
s'adresse au plus précaire parce qu'il
faut quand même cuisiner derrière
ils ont pas le choix en vrai enfin la
plupart elle l'a dit elle a commencé à
utiliser cette application pourquoi
parce qu'elle était donc aujourd'hui
c'est rentré dans ses habitudes
en fait la souvent récupéré empêcher le
gaspillage ou en fait la sobriété c'est
ça la sobriété en fait il y a déjà
beaucoup de gens qui la font parce
qu'ils sont pauvres par exemple sur le
chauffage je m'étais pas le chauffage à
19 degrés avant je me dis juste
simplement pas le chauffage pour la
nourriture c'est pareil on prend le
premier prix je veux dire les gens se
débrouillent et donc et ces applications
là elles sont nécessaires à la fois
parce que elles permettent à certaines
personnes de trouver des solutions pour
sortir de la précarité mais nous on veut
pas aider les gens à sortir de la
précarité en leur donnant les les voilà
les ce qui reste au fond du sac on veut
juste leur donner suffisamment pour
qu'il puisse vivre dignement en revanche
elle est intéressante cette application
parce que une conscience écologique
qu'on a en se disant à éviter de
gaspiller en plus de jeter
cette application n'est pas une mesure
de lutte contre la pauvreté qui est
politiquement acceptable parce que si
jamais vous partez du principe que vous
allez sortir les gens de la pauvreté en
leur donnant quelques chèques ou une
application qui leur donner
attention parce que c'est capable de
tenter de la République en marche ou le
RN ce genre de choses donc je fais
attention mais par contre écologie
écologiquement c'est c'est un
indispensable parce que il va falloir
enfin moi quand je pense la politique je
pense beaucoup à bientôt à quoi va
ressembler le monde dans 40 60 ans parce
que j'y serai et je me dis que il va
falloir avoir ses applications qui vous
permettent d'aller voir le voisin
d'aller récupérer ce qu'il a à côté en
fait il faut retourner enfin avec
Internet tous ces globalisé et on voit
tout à l'échelle mondiale et peut-être
qu'il faut retourner à des petits
réseaux une surconsommation une
surproduction en fait ça vient au départ
de bien sûr mais quand je vous disais
que je pense la politique a quoi elle
ressemblera dans 40 ou 60 le plan de
sobriété d'Emmanuel Macron finalement
c'est ça non c'est dire arrêtons de
produire trop arrêtons de consommer
en cause la société de consommation et
c'est ça le problème notre problème
vis-à-vis du réchauffement climatique
c'est que nous ça veut dire non parce
que eux ce qu'ils disent c'est attention
à certains moments il va y avoir des
tensions donc on évite on évite les
surtensions
pense que je dis et en fait ce que dit
la nupesse c'est que il va falloir
sortir d'une société de la société de
consommation et sa société cette société
de consommation c'est pas uniquement le
pouvoir politique qui peut y mettre fin
c'est les pouvoirs économiques parce que
ce sont les grands groupes les grandes
entreprises qui à travers la publicité à
travers les offres constantes à travers
aussi ce qu'on a sur nos téléphones avec
de la pub constamment des lumières qui
s'agitent on est constamment incité à
consommer et non seulement c'est pas ça
pour soi c'est pas vous savez on parle
beaucoup de détresse mental des jeunes
le rapport que la jeunesse peut avoir
aux réseaux sociaux qui montrent tout le
temps des belles vies tout ça mais ça
aussi c'est une société de consommation
qui entretient un mal-être et il va
falloir sortir de ça et Macron ne dit
pas ça oui revenons-en à cette
application parce que ça veut pas dire
dans le reportage elle va s'attaquer
aussi à un gros scandale c'est la date
de péremption elle va mettre des petits
stickers sur certains produits en disant
regardez goûter et vous verrez que vous
pouvez le manger même si ce n'est passé
elle va aussi faire des logiciels auprès
des grandes surfaces pour qu'on vende
des yaourts est-ce que vous quand vous
avez un yaourt de 6 mois dans votre égo
vous le mangez vous ça dépend je connais
mes yaourts
dangereusement non plus mais
bah yaourt à partir du moment où yaourt
est bon vous voilà mais vous mais vous
savez il y a je pense que ça je l'ai je
l'ai appris à quoi il y a quelques mois
parce que on me l'a pris on m'a dit
parce qu'en fait on apprend plus aux
enfants aujourd'hui à manger on apprend
enfin et je pense vos parents je te les
yaourts
etc vous en pensez ça en fait mes
parents mes parents ils m'ont ils m'ont
enseigné mais beaucoup moins que
d'autres déjà parti il y a quand même
quelque chose qui est intéressant à voir
c'est euh on apprend beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus profondément aux filles
qu'au garçon et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
vous voyez que la plupart du temps et
bah elle va croyez-moi toujours
aujourd'hui vous avez l'éducation à
l'alimentation à la nourriture à la
cuisine elle est très genrée et je pense
et il y a certaines personnes qui disent
mais c'est à la famille s'occuper
d'enseigner ces choses-là oui mais en
fait vous avez beaucoup de familles qui
ne le font pas parce que elles ne le
elle ne savent pas elle-même ou parce
qu'elles ne peuvent pas ou parce que ça
ne s'est pas fait et je pense que
l'école devrait s'intéresser de
justement ça aux enfants d'enseigner
qu'il y a certains produits des
enseignements aux fruits aux légumes
à l'utilisation est-ce que vous savez
cuisiner sans déchet est-ce que vous
utilisez par exemple les pelures de
pommes de terre est-ce que vous utilisez
tout dans les pommes et les fois
j'apprends j'apprends grâce à internet
j'essaie de regarder des petites vidéos
des recettes cuisine mais sur l'école
des fruits sur l'école je suis pas
d'accord de dire que l'école fait des
efforts parce que avant on avait des
sorties scolaires moi j'ai fait ça on en
avait fait des ressortir scolaires dans
la nature aujourd'hui ça n'existe
quasiment plus les sorties scolaires
pour que les enfants ils aillent au
contact de la nature qu'ils aillent
visiter des agriculteurs
regardez regardez regardez
les retours que j'ai du terrain de la
part notamment des fédérations de
parents d'élèves c'est que c'est sorti
là elles ont énormément diminué et
souvent à cause de ceux qui veulent plus
d'élevage etc mais ça tombe bien
et
le problème c'est que ce n'est pas
institutionnalisé c'est souvent le
professeur qui doit monter le projet
lui-même selon moi l'école elle doit
être beaucoup plus volontariste pas
uniquement pour apprendre aux enfants à
manger mais pour apprendre aux enfants
comment fonctionne la nature parce que
c'est bien de ça donc il est question
dans notre siècle aussi un petit peu non
on pourrait se dire c'est aux parents de
le faire et où vous observez que
beaucoup de parents ne le font pas et
donc du coup vous avez des enfants qui
se retrouvent dans des situations bah
ils n'ont pas eu cette éducation et mise
à part faire des reproches à leurs
parents ils peuvent rien faire d'autre
c'est pour ça que l'école doit s'en
mêler et elle doit se mêler elle doit
avoir une philosophie politique dans
l'école qui doit être celle d'enseigner
l'harmonie entre les êtres humains et la
nature et du coup organiser beaucoup
plus de classe verte expliquer comment
poussent les plantes les mettre au
contact et aussi leur renseigner ben ça
vous pouvez encore le manger après et je
trouve que l'école n'est pas assez
volontariste sur le sujet il y a une loi
qui s'appelle la loi Garros sur le
gaspillage qui vise à lutter contre le
gaspillage cette loi elle pourrait
évoluer parce qu'il y a une proposition
de loi commune entre Renaissance et les
républicains pour diminuer la surface
des supermarchés donc au lieu de 400
mètres carrés ce serait les 200 m² qui
seraient aussi obligé jusqu'à 200 mètres
carrés on serait obligé de de donner
enfin au-delà de 200 mètres carrés
est-ce que vous vous êtes prêt à une
proposition de loi comme celle là est-ce
que vous trouvez ça bien que finalement
les supermarchés soient obligés de
donner bien sûr
à chaque fois qu'on peut éviter le
gaspillage c'est souhaitable et nous on
fera des propositions en ce sens mais
c'est là c'est là ou parfois je suis
assez mal à l'aise dans cette Assemblée
nationale de voir des autres groupes qui
se disent regardez on a lutter par
exemple contre le gaspillage et ne
jamais aller directement sur le problème
de fond qui est la société de
consommation parce qu'en fait on
gaspirait pas autant si jamais on ne
vivait pas dans une société de
consommation on produit à outrance et on
encourage à consommer à outrance il est
là le fond du problème et ils ne veulent
pas aller sur ce sujet là parce que ça
remettrait en cause des systèmes
peut-être même des amitiés et ils ne
sont pas prêts à ça vous allez mettre ça
dans l'atmosphère et dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée allez on va passer au
dessert à présent et c'est le péché
mignon
alors le temps du sucré est venu
Brigitte avec un Paris-Brest et oui oui
Bing un beau gâteau très bon c'est un
totem de la pâtisserie française pour la
petite histoire c'est l'organisateur
d'une d'une course de vélo Paribas qui
avait demandé à un pâtissier de lui
faire un gâteau et ben il a fait un
gâteau en forme de roue de vélo
aujourd'hui on trouve des paris-brestres
carrés ou même rectiligne est-ce que
pour vous le vrai Paris-Brest c'est
celui-ci rond comme une route bicyclette
pour moi il est rond voilà à titre
personnel
j'en ai jamais vu et bon après dans les
pâtisseries un peu un peu branché et
pourquoi le Paris-Brest parce que ça m'a
choqué quand je suis arrivé à
l'Assemblée nationale j'avais à la
buvette vous aviez plein de Paris Brest
plein de Paris Brest et en fait
et du coup quand j'arrive à l'Assemblée
nationale et que moi avant j'étais avec
mes pâtes au curry et que je vois tous
ces Paris Brest mais je me dis mais en
fait on vit pas dans le même monde quoi
et vous voyez ce Paris-Brest ça vaut
probablement un Paris-Brest comme ça ça
vaut probablement quatre fois le plat
qu'on vient de manger ensemble et quand
je vois qu'ensuite
pas
à Paris Brest dans une très bonne
pâtisserie ça vaut dans une très chère
pâtisserie ça vaut 8 euros ça vaut une
fois et demi votre plaque et bah vous
savez oui oui après aujourd'hui ils
peuvent pas se payer
un pari Brest j'ai une très bonne
pâtisserie je suis dans une boulangerie
pâtisserie de Carrefour
vous avez des jeunes qui mangent des
plats à 2 euros et vous avez une toute
la classe politique et économique
dirigeante qui se nourrit de Paris-Brest
énorme qui vaut quatre fois le prix des
repas que les jeux avec les jeunes
mangent tous les jours et quand je suis
arrivé à l'Assemblée nationale du
shopping comme ça sur les députés vous
affaiblissez vous-même et et vous savez
je suis pas justement je suis pas en
train de dire que les députés devraient
vivre dans la photo en train de dire que
les étudiants devraient pas vivre dans
cette pauvreté parce que je suis pas en
train de dire que enfin nous non on a un
mode de vie qui est le nôtre mais le
vrai sujet c'est pas à nous
c'est les milliardaires ce sont des
personnes qui accumulent mais des qui
qui assoit tout seul peut posséder
autant de richesses quand vous avez des
millions de personnes qui n'ont rien
alors
vous aimez le paris-brestre
je l'aime beaucoup mais je veux juste je
veux juste insister sur le fait que il y
a un véritable contraste entre ce que
moi j'ai pu vivre tous les jours on a
que j'arrive à comprendre ça et ça m'a
choqué merci à vous notre invitation à
table merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
politique à table sur LCP